nous sommes ici à voisins le bretonneux
devant le salon de bien-être de clergé
elle qui est coiffeuse énergéticienne et
nous allons tester la tripoter rapide
alors c'est une coupe de cheveux
énergétique qui doit harmoniser le corps
et l'esprit
allons voir ça de plus près nous sommes
avec clergé bonjour bonjour vous
décoiffer énergéticienne absolument quel
est le but final de cette coupe
énergétiques alors le but final de cette
coupe de cheveux énergétique
elle va être de stimuler donc batum au
bulbe pileux de stimuler votre énergie
vitale de des toxines et bush veut nous
apporter un effet bonne mine immédiat
maintenant que vous avez expliqué la
théorie on va passer à la pratique et
bien avec plaisir je suis
[Musique]
je pense donc la première partie qui est
le massage énergétique crânien ou g
venir stimuler tous les méridiens et
inviter notre sujet du jour à entrer
dans son monde intérieur
[Musique]
vous posez votre énergie dessus votre
intention
que tu mouilles est toute la chevelure à
la main
je passe à la deuxième partie où j'ai
rien des structures et a le cheveu
stimulante aux compétiteurs qui le je
vais vous invitez si vous le souhaitez à
repartir avec vos cheveux et puis à
trouver l'élément qui va correspondre le
mieux cette transformation à cette
conscientisation
nous sommes sur la troisième et dernière
partie health à la restructuration et
l'harmonisation rasoir je ventile à
chevelure fin de la sécher et avec le
coucou je lis tout simplement les
écailles qui va apporter beaucoup de
brillance de souplesse voilà la coupe
énergétique est terminée ou à gauche
veut plus doux plus ouvre l'esprit aussi
combien la deux coiffures énergéticiens
dans le monde alors nous sommes 250
coiffeur énergéticiens qui avons été
formés dans l'académie de gilles andrieu
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accueillis
merci à vous